Hey everybody, it's Mike. Good morning,
good afternoon, good evening depending
where you are. I'm in Chicago, so it's
11:00. It's not quite afternoon yet. And
I don't really like to call 11:00
morning. And I get started here in a
second. I'm just going through a couple
last minute checks to make sure
everything is working fine on my end.
And uh
if you hear me get silent or if you hear
me coughing, I am battling a uh
flu right now. I'm getting better
though, but uh maybe a a moment where it
just uh overwhelms me and I have to
start coughing. I'll try to do it off to
the side.
But let me just uh go through a couple
last minute checks here and I'll get
started.
Okay.
All right, looks like everything is uh
good to go. So, I'll get started. So,
you know what I want to talk about today
is, you know, we we finally released
this uh indicator. It's called the Show
Hand indicator. And
you know, and and really its whole point
is to help traders see where
institutional trading is taking place in
the market. Now, you know, when a trader
is executing a large order, all right, a
a big institutional trader,
um that starts to become obvious in the
order flow. That trader is quote showing
his hand, right? That hence the name the
Show Hand indicator. And characteristic
trading behaviors that reveal a trader's
strategy or position are such as, you
know, a large trade taking place
relative to surrounding volume. It's
something that sticks out um pretty
easily. Uh repeated trades at a specific
price levels on the bid or offer and
consistent order size or refreshing,
right? An iceberg order. Uh you know,
people always talk about iceberg orders
and you know, they do have an impact in
the market, especially when a market is
moving in a direction, right? If the
market is going up and you see an
iceberg order on the bid, you know,
that's providing support to the market.
Just as if a market starts trending down
and you see an iceberg order on the
offer coming in, you know, it shows that
there's uh more selling at a level on
the way down, which is important
information.
Now, when other market participants can
figure out a trader's intentions from
the visible trade activity, it leads to
front running by other traders, right?
You know, if you've ever um
studied or or practiced trading on the
uh price ladder, right? The depth of
market, the dome or the DOM, however you
want to call it, you know, there's some
guy who make
you know,
the the literature police
come out to me and say, "No, you're
saying dome
like d o m e and it should be DOM, you
know, that's semantics, right? There's
there's bigger things to worry about in
the market than whether you're
pronouncing uh the dome or the DOM
correctly, right? Some people say
tomato, some say tomato.
But, you know, if you've if you've ever
traded that way, you know that when you
see a big size order come in the market,
what's your first inclination to do is
sort of jump in front of it, right? Sort
of front run that um
that activity in the market. And when
there's a large trader, you know, with a
big order in the market and it's known,
well, what happens is you often have a
quicker market movement, right? You
know, in the in the old days when it was
uh you know, still trading in the pits,
it'd be like uh you know, if if you're
on the floor or if you're, you know, on
the phone with the the floor broker, if
you're an institutional trader or in a
squawk box, "Oh, uh Goldman's is buying.
Oh, you know, they
you know, Goldman's is buying, you know,
so you know, they're having a probably a
big order.
Your inclination is to uh sort of jump
in front and that's what uh you know, a
lot of locals would do
um you know, on the floors, you know,
they they see Salomon Brothers is
bidding, you know,
50 for 300.
They'll jump in and and
cuz they know that that's probably a
legitimate order. That's something they
can lean on. If they're wrong, they can
go against.
And
unfortunately for the big traders,
right? Once their intentions is known to
the public, that increases their
execution costs, right? Because they end
up having to pay a worse price.
So, what they're really trying to do is
they're trying to hide their intentions.
And the Show Hand indicator is designed
to alert you when the big trader is
active in the market, right? Sometimes
it's very obvious. This was this
morning, right? This was in um E-minis.
This is a range-based chart.
And there was a big uh there was a big
bid or sorry, a big offer in the market
this morning at 45. Um you can see the
big size coming in there, 1140 uh 4
2444, right? And and you had a nice
little sell-off this morning. This was
just after the cash open.
Other times it's uh it's not so obvious,
right? It's it's kind of massaged in
there with the normal volume.
Okay? And what looks like just normal
volume coming in and you might not pick
it up. And that's what the Show Hand
indicator is designed to do. It's
designed to show you It reads the order
flow. You do not need a footprint chart.
It is not a footprint chart. It's an
indicator that will run on a normal bar
chart or um I don't know I want to say
bar chart anymore, really. The the term
Hardly anybody looks at bar charts. Most
people look at candlestick charts. 90%
probably 95% of people that don't use uh
footprint probably just stick with uh
candlestick charts, not so much bar
charts.
So, over the years, how have
institutions responded? Well, the first
way was to develop more sophisticated
order execution strategies. It's not so
much as, you know, they've got a
thousand E-minis to buy, you just buy a
thousand. No, they break it up. Um they
got waves, subwaves, you know, they'll
they'll work it in over a certain time
period or percentage of volume, um work
bids, lift offers, etc. You know, if
it's depending on if it's a buy or sell,
so they're going to break it into
smaller pieces.
Um
But the beauty is, you know, with the
order flow,
when something trades, it shows up in
the time and sales and as a result it's
going to show up in the footprint,
right? It's going to show up in
as a trade that took place in the
market, right? Cuz what really what
we're looking at is actual trades that
take place in the market, not
you know, bids and offers below the
current bid or offers above the current
offer. What we're dealing with is
traders actual commitments to the
market. They actually got into a
position,
right? Or potentially got out of or
trying to get out of a position. Okay?
Cuz remember, not every trade it it's
easy to think that every trade that you
see going through the market is is a new
position being put on. Sometimes it's a
position
that's being taken unwound, right? Being
taken off.
Um so
you know, breaking orders into smaller
pieces really disguises what they're
doing
a lot. I mean, you know, iceberg I the
whole point of an iceberg is to disguise
the order
and show the minimum amount possible
without affecting the market. And
sometimes they're going to create false
signals to mislead
uh pattern followers, right? People that
watch uh a footprint or
not necessarily a footprint, but watch,
you know,
a simple bar chart or candlestick chart
looking for patterns, okay? And really
what you want to do is you want to be
able to identify where
the institutional buying or
institutional selling is coming in. This
is crude oil this morning, okay? I'm
going to take you through
um
real charts, real examples uh
just from today, okay? Just keep it
simple, you know, I chose today today is
Veterans Day. Market might be um
you know, a little bit lighter than
normal.
So
you know, just bear that in mind. And to
be honest with you, last week was the
election and the markets were extremely
uh volatile. You know, last week is not
necessarily indicative of what every
week looks like in the markets, but um
you know, it it it was a crazy week. You
know, honestly, I know for myself, I was
looking forward to this election being
over and I could sort of get back to my
normal life, but uh
I think it's going to be a a little bit
of time before I I get get off of uh
Twitter reading uh the news about uh the
elections and and all that stuff. Now,
I'm just going to take you through the
settings really quick here, okay? So,
you know, you when you
load the indicator, right? You just load
it as a normal indicator, right? You
download the zip and then you um
you know, you you just go to the
NinjaTrader control panel and you just
uh import it you would any other
any other third-party indicator, right?
You just click on um you know, tools
under your thing, you'd find ShowHand
and then you'd import it, okay? I I'm
not going to do that right now,
but I've already done it. And then um
you're going to install it on your
that installs it on the chart. So, what
you're going to do is you open up a
chart. For today's purposes, I'll just
stay with a uh candlestick chart as
opposed to a a footprint chart. Um
but you'd get the same signals whether
you're using a footprint chart or a
uh candlestick chart.
It just it reads the order flow, okay?
So, a couple things to to note. On your
chart, you'd have to have tick replay
enabled to see the historical uh
signals, okay?
And
once you
open up your chart, what you got to do
is you got to find it in here, Order
Flow ShowHand, click on it so it appears
down here, okay? Then you're going to
enter in your license token that uh is
sent to you separately after you
purchase, okay?
Very few settings. Um
and I'll just take you through them
really quick here. Let me just get my
slide deck up here cuz I have it on a
actually I got it on a uh
in here.
So, really the settings are there's a
swing filter, right? Enable swing filter
and the swing period.
Um the disparity range, which is the
main one. I'll discuss that in a moment.
Um prominent point of control filter.
So, if you want to have uh
signals where the bar has to have a
prominent point of control, that's the
setting that you would enable. The
momentum strength,
which is um
you know, if you want to catch the uh
signals only in a strong directional
move, that's momentum strength. We have
a sound alert and the other one is uh
trade entry signal.
So, just really quick. The disparity
range is is sort of the main setting,
okay? It's the most important setting.
And the default is set to 150. So, when
you first load the indicator, it's set
to 150, which is kind of mid-range,
actually a little bit stronger than
mid-range. And it's the measure of
strength of the institutional order flow
appearing in the market. And
you know, if you're
going to ask me what goes into the
disparity disparity range, not
disparaging, disparity range, is, you
know, how the order flow is is being
transacted in the market, um you know,
relative to
um surrounding volume, okay? And that's
going to give you the clue as to, you
know, is there actual institutional
activity or not?
Because how you know, what's the sign of
institutional activity? It is an uptick
in volume
that is out of the uh usual
range.
So, the lowest level you can set it to
is 50, and that's going to cause the
most signals, right? Because that's the
minimum strength. Um 250 is sort of the
highest. I mean, you could put a higher
level, but really 250, I think is about
as high as you need to go. Um we even
wrote in there disparity range of 50 to
250.
And of course, you know, when you go
higher, you know, at the 250, you're
going to get
fewer signals cuz it's the highest
about the highest measuring cuz to be
honest, once you get above 250, it's
there's not much of a difference.
Um
It's the highest measure of
institutional activity appearing in the
market as measured by the indicator.
Now, while you can enter any number
between 50 and
250, like 89, which is a fib number, um
you can enter 51, 52, 53, all the way up
to, you know, 247 to 248 to 249 to 250.
Honestly, I just prefer to go in
multiples of say 25, meaning like 50,
75, 100, 125, 150, 175, 200, 225, and
250.
Again, you're free to set it to whatever
you like. I
I I just find that um
it's easier to sort of keep it in
multiples. You know, I mean, I use 25s.
Some people might want to use multiples
of 10 or but whatever. You can use any
any number in between there. Now,
one of the other filters is the
prominent point of control filter.
Right? And it's disabled. To enable it,
you just click on there
on that box next to it. And what that
would mean is the bar would have to have
a prominent point of control. Right? A
point of prominent point of control is a
point of control in the bar that
matters. So, if it it doesn't have a
prominent point of control, but it has,
you know, it's within the disparity
disparity range and say the momentum
strength,
but you have prominent point of control
filter enabled, and there is not a
prominent point of control, it won't
give the signal.
Okay?
So, just bear that in mind, especially
if you're in some markets that are, you
know, like MNQ or
um
NQY M,
and you're on like a
a minute-based chart
where you're not going to get a lot of
prominent point of controls, um you're
going to filter yourself out of a lot of
trades.
Now, the momentum strength
the setting is set to six, which is the
strongest level. Okay, and what the
momentum strength does is it it just
measures the momentum of the market. To
disable it, if you don't want to use any
momentum strength, then I'll show you
guys some charts
um
with it enabled and with it disabled.
You would set it to zero to disabled,
and again, you know, six is this is the
strongest. Um
one is sort of the the minimum amount
of momentum. Three is kind of the
average. Obviously, six is strongest.
You could still use two, three, two,
four, and five, which is just getting a
little bit stronger on the spectrum. But
me personally, I either use disable
or six. Um sometimes I'll just use one
again if I'm testing, um
I'll use one
as just sort of, you know, what's the
minimum amount, you know, is there a
difference between the minimum and
and not.
Now,
before I get into uh
some of the charts, just
well, we'll come back to this. These are
sort of common settings um that you
would use, like 150 disparity range,
which is the default setting, right?
Which is set for most markets. 150 and
six, okay? Now, I'm going to show you
the range of 150 and zero, zero meaning
momentum, um 150 and three, 50 and six.
50 is the the lowest disparity disparity
range with six the highest momentum.
Um
and then the lowest with uh say zero
momentum. And then we'll talk about the
swing filter.
And, you know, compare like 100 and
three, 100 disparity range and three
momentum versus
100 and six, okay? And momentum filters.
All right, so let's just go to the
charts here, just really quick here. So,
this is uh
crude oil. Okay, now that I see there's
some questions coming in. Yes, the the
this is going to be recorded. You'll be
sent the recording
um
as well. And you know, these things like
the settings
um
you know, I'm going to put that in the I
mean, it's in the recording as well, but
um
you know, it'll be there in the user
guide as well. Um
Well, if you don't care about the past
historical settings, you you should be
able to run it without tick replay,
okay?
But honestly, it doesn't slow it down.
You know, there's this misconception
that tick replay slows things down. If
you're if you're on a
I I I don't have any issues with uh
speed or anything like that. So,
let me just uh
Here, I'll show you. Well, for now, I'll
just turn this off.
Uh well,
no. This one does require it. I'm sorry
about that. It does require it. My my
programmer made this pop up here. This
indicator requires tick replay to
function
properly, okay?
So, it doesn't need it. I apologize for
that.
Um
But uh
it's some of the new feature he put on
these.
You know, NinjaTrader keeps making some
changes on the back ends, and sometimes
the stuff now requires it. I I know
before in the past like with seven, you
could get away with it.
But anyway, okay, so this is the default
settings here,
okay?
150 and six. You can see swing filter is
turned off. Primary point of control is
disabled.
And I have this
We'll talk about this later, the trade
entry signal. Okay, trade entry signal
is is
is kind of like a filter I use to
keep me out of bad trades. And what it
means is, you know, the market has to be
moving in a direction of my trade
relatively soon. It's got to move at
least two ticks within um three bars in
this case, okay?
So,
crude oil, all right, default settings.
All right, let's just go through some
markets really quick. Just the main
markets, all right, that I'll discuss
today. This is uh
What is it? Euro currency right here.
Okay.
Crude and Euro currency actually seem to
be moving uh
very similar. Gold
also
selling off today.
Um
Now, quite nicely. Gosh, we sold off
from 26
Here, you know, this area we're
consolidated around 2680. Gosh, we're
down uh
That's a big move in or 60 rather, not
80. Um down into the 20s. We start
seeing some buy signals come in.
Um
bonds, ZBs.
Now,
you know, ZB bonds have moved
a lot slower, okay? So, there's actually
no signals today. Today's kind of quiet
in the bonds, but you see on on Friday.
And again, um I'm going to talk about
this here in a second, the um
the different settings. So, these are
the default settings, okay?
And
well,
let's take a look, you know, MES. What
MES do?
How's that looking now?
I think uh
All right, this is MES
this morning.
Okay, I'm going to I'm going to talk
about these lines, what these lines
represent.
Um,
these
zones. So, we'll get to that. Don't
worry, guys. Um,
all right, so
let's just, uh,
play around with it a little bit. Okay,
so again, default settings 150 and 6.
Momentum is set to strongest.
Okay, if you take off the momentum, I'll
just leave this here. So, you can see uh
zero is to disable it.
Now, it's looking for signals that
appear anywhere, right? It could be
you know, so you're getting a bit more,
right? Before you you had, uh,
Okay, let's get my crosshairs here. So,
let me make this crosshairs a little bit
stronger.
Right? So, you got like a buy signal
here,
followed by a sell signal, sell signal.
Um,
you know, a couple of them more buys. I
think you had the sell wasn't there
before using the
taking When you take momentum off,
right? So, let's compare it really
quick. This is zero.
Change it back to six.
Okay. So, yeah, so that sell is gone.
Your buy is gone. Now,
just really quick,
right? Trade entry signal.
So, you can see like
there is
this little blue zone here, this little
blue zone here.
Right? There's one here. There's some
stuff in here. There's these little
zones being drawn out. What that's
telling me is that there was a
conditions were met for a potential buy
or sell signal, but
the market's not moving in the direction
that I want it to move in the time
period
that I
that I um
have told it to. So, right? You can see
here it's through two and three. So,
price level in ticks is two. So, it's
got to move
two ticks
from if it's a buy from the high of the
entry bar or for a sell from the low
of the signal bar rather, not entry bar,
from the signal bar.
And it's got to do that within three
bars.
Okay? And again, I put a max on here of
five. So, you know, you're not
getting, you know, a signal
appearing
and then it takes, you know, if you're
on a minute chart, takes 10 minutes for
it to move. No, you know, when something
happens in the order flow, I expect it
to happen sooner
rather than later. If I disable this,
right? So, you're going to see up here
maybe a a signal, a signal, some signals
that don't really um
work out, you know, in the sense that,
you know, if you take those trades,
you'd be stopped out.
All right. Now, you see it coming in
here.
You see this buy signal, right? If you
took this buy signal, you'd be stopped
out. If you took this buy signal, you'd
be stopped out. Um you know, some of
these shorts, you'd be stopped out.
Some of these longs, you'd be stopped
out. That's why I
have that option in there, trade entry
signal,
specifically,
right?
To keep me out of these areas
where
the market doesn't follow through.
Um it could just be a big order going
through the market. All right, that's
that's causing the order flow to
give you a signal, right?
All right, so you don't see any the buy
here, the sell here cuz that's, you
know, in choppy markets, that's what's
going to happen to you. You get chopped
up. It's you really want the trades that
are going to
you know,
be explosive.
That can happen cuz the market is is
starting to move in its uh in the
direction.
Okay?
Now,
these zones, you could choose to have
them or not have them.
Excuse me. I like to have them. Um
that's this under the visuals. Signal
box draw mode is res until tested. So,
it's going to draw it out until it's
until the price comes back to those
levels. If
I don't want to use it, I would change
this uh
Where is it here? Signal box width to
zero.
Okay?
And then that would
basically cause it to uh not draw out
the zones, right?
If you have it uh until There's two ways
you could do it, right? Until tested or
fixed, right? So, you can see here it's
just giving you the actual signals.
Um again, it's up to you if you want to
use those or not. The the other way you
can do it is fixed, okay? Which if you
just want it out, you know, a fixed
number of bars,
say five, right? I I changed it to five.
I have it fixed. What it's going to do
is going to draw out
that blue or red zone, blue for bullish
or red for bearish, over the next five
bars.
Okay?
But, you know, I'm kind of a visual
person.
So, when it's fixed, right? You could do
it one, you know, you could draw it out
50 or or 25, however you want. I just
like to keep it in fixed here. So, when
it's fixed, it's being drawn out
until price comes back to those levels.
Okay? Because if I see something, right?
If I see the market going up, right?
Rallying, we get a high, start coming
off, and I see, "Oh, I hear I got the
zone being drawn out." If it's like
this,
right?
I think, "Hey, you know what? We got a
zone starting to be drawn out here.
Where can we trade back to? Is is these
levels, potentially."
Okay? And we come right down to these
levels, rotate around, then I got
another zone being drawn out here. You
see how the market comes right back to
it.
Okay? But
don't get fixated on these zones as the
market has to come back to exactly that
level. It's nice when it does, but um I
mean, you could use these as stops as
well.
Um you know, if you're long,
but you know, when I see a market start
running away from you know, starting to
create a zone and starts to run away
from it, um to me, that's
that's a good signal. Okay?
Now,
so, that's 150 and say six, right? If
you were to lower the the level,
right? 50,
right? That which is the
absolute
lowest I think you should go.
Okay?
And you have even momentum strength
still at six, which is, you know, on the
side of momentum, you're going to get
a lot of signals, right? It's going to
capture every move in the market pretty
much, but probably going to capture some
moves that you don't
necessarily want. Um
and you know,
would you use 50? You know, some people
um
might, you know, cuz I know some traders
they like to have a reason to add on to
a position. Okay? And if you know,
you're getting a lot of signals, yeah,
you can get long, you can add on, add
on, add on, you know,
finally get your reversal signal up
here, get short, get short, get short.
Again, it's not for for everybody, but
again, if you're trading something like,
you know, in the overnight session,
um with slightly lesser volume, you may
consider it.
Okay? Now,
that's with momentum strength. If you're
using such a low disparity range,
um you know, 50,
I do recommend keeping the uh momentum
strength on.
Um if you turn it off, you're going to
get,
you know,
a lot of signals.
Um
And just show you here real quick.
Again, you know, if if you're trading in
the evening time, you know, don't
forget, you know, institutions also
trade in the evening time. How do I
know? Cuz I've done it. I did it for for
a long time. So, you can see a lot more
signals here, which again, for me
personally, if you're going to use
50, the lowest, um
I think it's
prudent to keep the uh
momentum strength turned on to its to
its highest level. Um but you can see
like in in other markets, right? Like go
back to crude oil.
Okay, so this is 50, the lowest, right?
You you see a lot, right? That's with
the uh
momentum strength set at
zero, right? I I do believe you should
enable it.
All right, to to sort of
keep you just, you know, on the side of
the way the market's going, um you know,
for the most part. I mean, it will run
into some areas like this where it
struggles just because the market's
going sideways. But again, you have it
set so low
that um
it's probably not going to be
very effective. I think 50 is too low.
But again, you know, you could adjust
it. You know, I I sent out an email the
other day with fib numbers. I know
people love to use fibs. I mean, you
could use 89, right? 89 is a fib number.
Um let me just show you here.
You know, 89. But again, you don't have
to use 89. You could use
uh 75. You could use 100. Um
you know, this is
What is that's a that's a 1-minute
chart. Um even if you go like on a on
even a faster chart, say a 30-second,
you know,
it's funny sometimes people go, "Oh, I
can't use a 30-second chart." But then
they'll use like a a four-range chart,
which is, you know, just as fast as a as
a 30-second chart. Um
you know, so
as you go a little bit faster
chart-wise, I think you do need to
um consider what you're putting on as
your disparity
range.
You know,
faster chart,
I think it's it's better to have a
higher disparity range. This is again on
the 30-second chart. Now, if you're on a
market like say bonds or
you know, we'll take a look at ultra
bonds here.
Okay.
It's ultra bonds.
150 and 6. You know, again, if we're
ultra bonds, if you went down to say 89,
cuz it's a little faster moving market,
you know, you can catch some of these
moves that are taking place.
Um I don't even know if you you might
want to adjust even the momentum
strength.
You know, I'd go down, cut it in half to
three, and see how it looks. Looks very
similar. Um
you know, even if you went down to zero,
you know, it's still basically the same.
Okay.
You see how it was on Friday.
Yeah, let's go look at say Euro
currency.
Oh, wait a second here.
That's a 30-second chart. If you go to
uh
30-second on ultra bonds is wishful
thinking, but it still gives you an
idea.
Okay, so this is ultra bonds today
and Friday. Forgot that I had it on a
30-second chart. Um
you know, short here, short here
the way down.
Um
and again, this is with 89
and zero on the momentum strength.
Right? If I had it set at six
on momentum strength
right? It doesn't catch that one up
there.
Now
swing filter, okay? So, if you're going
to use swing filter
you would not use momentum strength,
right? Cuz it goes against each other.
So, you have to turn momentum strength
off by setting at zero
and
you know, swing filter whatever your
period you want, right? Default is one.
You know, I don't know. You could
probably set it at something like five
for a swing.
Um
you know, so it's just going to capture
the swing here, swing here, swing here,
swing highs. There's There's no signal
on swing lows.
Um you know, going back a few more days,
you can see it there. Like Euro
currency, 6E.
Right? Here you're trying to pick swing
highs and swing lows. Okay?
You know, crude oil.
And again, you know, if if you don't
want to use these zones, you can just
disable the zones. I I just like to see
it. For me, it's more visual.
Okay.
So, yeah, you do need tick.
You do need the tick replay on. I
apologize for that. It does It does need
to be on.
Um
So, here I just uh
Okay, so someone asked about uh some
more examples in bonds here.
Okay, so for example, bonds. If Let me
turn off the swing filter. If you were
set it as low as possible, 50.
Okay. Cuz bonds tend to be a slow-moving
market. Okay.
I'm going to turn off the momentum.
The strength.
Setting the range at 50. Now, I do have
the
um trade entry signal turned on. Okay,
now then again, you know, today is kind
of a a quietish day.
But you can see here, right, with the
trade entry signal enabled,
you just have the one trade today.
If you
disable the trade entry signal,
you're going to see
signals coming in,
you know, here, here, here, here. Here.
Now again, it's up to you whether you
want to use it or not. I am a big
believer in it. What you could do also
is you could enable it and you could set
it at five and five, you know, sort of
the max. So,
it's got to move with, you know,
uh
Actually, hang on here.
What am I doing here?
Oh,
trade price level in ticks one, which is
the minimum.
What I was doing it was telling it to
So here, I
signal signal signal. Think to remember
trade price level in ticks.
It's got to move if you set it at one.
So what that means is it has to move one
tick within the next
five bars. Okay, so when I have it set
at two and three means it has to move
two ticks
within three bars, right? The default is
two and three. By making it one,
it's got to move one tick within five
bars.
Okay, so you can see here, right? Signal
signal signal. This is bonds. If you go
back to another market like tens, ZN,
same sort of settings.
Let's take a look.
See, it says calculating up here in the
corner.
This is
the bonds.
See, a couple short signals, longs,
shorts, longs in here.
Um,
so, you know, for us,
the slower moving markets like interest
rates, all right, let's take a look at
ultra bonds.
For generally slower moving markets like
interest rates, you can disable the
momentum filter.
All right, here's ultra bonds.
All right.
This is today. Go back to Friday on last
night.
Um,
on Friday,
me per se, I like to use um
I like the move to happen sooner rather
than later. That's why I have it set it
two and three. But again, if if you want
it to say, "Hey, you know what? It's got
to move one tick within the next three
bars." You you can change it
there. All right, and you'll probably
get slightly fewer signals.
All right, or you could even move it to
one and one, meaning the next bar has to
start making that move.
Here.
It's got to move one tick
in the next bar.
Meaning it's got to move in the
direction within one tick of the next
bar. Okay?
And you can see how it looks there.
You know, a good contract that not many
Americans
are familiar with is bonds.
Um you know, the German is just straight
German 10-year trades on Eurex.
Yeah, you can see you know, all bearish
in here, bullish on the way up,
obviously bearish here, all bullish
here.
You know, this nice big move up, nice
big move down, a little chop back and
forth.
Um but again, you have it set at such a
low number,
50 and six,
you know, or 50 and zero. If you made it
50 and six
on the bonds,
it all cleans up some of that chop
that was there.
Does keep you out of a couple of these
shorts from a little bit higher, but you
can still capture most of the major move
in the bonds.
So, you know, if you're
in Chicago or the US, you know, and
you're up around 1:00 in the morning
and can't sleep, um take a look at bonds
once in a while.
Um
again, that's on a on a one bonds is
actually a market I think you You even
trade with good volume.
Could even go down to a a shorter time
frame, 30 second chart even. There's
some nice
moves to be had
in bonds
uh during the trading day.
Now,
just really quick here.
Uh some
you know,
there's about 40 or 50
major futures markets out there, okay?
But not everyone is is looks at them.
And it's just interesting because
sometimes I get letters from people
saying, "Hey, what about this market?"
You know, like um
I'll get that in a minute, but you know,
one of them is Swiss franc, okay? And
and Swiss franc is is a market that
not everybody
is interested in in trading because it's
kind of thin at times. You could see in
here, right? This is in the morning
where it just you know, trades one
contract, you know what I mean? You
know, one price level.
So, it's a lot of these flat lines,
okay? But this is the I just want to
show you something really quick, okay?
Um just scrunch up this chart, get this
this morning here, okay? So, you can
see, you know, during US hours, much
more volume. So, you're seeing these
bars.
But
and again, this is a 30 second chart,
which is kind of quick. So, this is
a 50
This is set at the minimum volume,
right? 50.
Or disparity arranged on volume's
disparity range of 50.
With the momentum strength of six.
Okay, so you you're seeing
um
you know, a lot of signals. And
sometimes, you know, people are like,
"Well, how does it look on, you know,
like a five range chart or something?"
You know,
as you can see, it's just
a little bit more pronounced, you know,
all the institutional selling. And for
some people it feels like almost every
bar has got a signal on it, right? Which
is
you know, the the the selling, you know,
what this market is interesting cuz you
see the red bars
all got like the shorts on. You don't
see any bullish
green, you know, any any signals on the
on these green candles, any any, you
know, the the blue arrows would be
bullish signals.
This gives you an idea of the amount of
the type of selling that was taking
place overnight.
All right, in the Swiss franc. Even
though, you know, if you were to look on
the footprint, you see it's kind of it
looks like light volume, but it's being
detected as
you know, this actually institutional
selling. And you see this market's been
under pressure
all night basically. There's been some
buying that's come in right now for the
last several hours we've been sort of
consolidating in here and you see it's
kind of mixed. But all night it's just
been under pressure.
Right? That's why you don't see any of
the
you know, the the the buy arrows.
But if you, you know,
bump up the disparity range to 150 where
it's going to become a bit clearer,
right? You can see even in here, right?
Just you got less
signals, right? The less triangles.
But
you can still see the strong selling
that's taking place in this market from,
you know, overnight, right? Down into
the mornings.
Um
Yes, everyone's asking, will there be a
copy of this presentation? Yep.
The there's a
there is a recording. It's being
recorded now.
Here's a second, guys.
I got a cough.
Yeah, sorry about that.
Excuse me. Sorry, I just had a cough.
Um
Okay, let me take a look at some
questions here.
Okay, so
Jean-Pierre asked, "How how does it
catch the the big hands?" Well, what it
does is is it reads what's going through
on the order flow.
Okay? And it's from there, you know, on
the footprint,
it does all the reading of the footprint
for you, so that you don't have to sit
here
and try to analyze it yourself. Okay?
Um
you know, if if I were to
put it on here,
right? Cuz you know, when you look at a
footprint,
unless you know exactly what you're
looking for,
then
Okay, let's make sure our show hand and
this is just the default settings. Um
unless you know what you're looking for
in the footprint, right? It it's going
to be hard for you to understand what
you're looking at. Let's go back to the
minute chart here.
Right? So, it does that heavy lifting
for you, right? So, give us buy signal.
Let me make sure I got the right signals
on here.
What I'm going to do
is I'm going to make it
much bigger. Make it 15.
That way it'll stand out more.
Okay, so you can see that the sell
signal is reading what's going on in the
order flow, right? Here's your big arrow
up here, the bullish signal. So it's
reading what's taking place here in the
order flow.
All right, so that you don't have to do
it. There's a sell signal there.
Obviously some buys coming in here.
Okay?
Cuz again, you know, if you don't
understand how to read order flow. And
again, this just reads a certain aspect
of order flow. This doesn't replace
a footprint chart and read all the
different aspects of order flow. It what
it's doing is it's reading the volume
traded on the bid, the volume on the
offer. Um, it's doing its analysis
of the volume and it's basically telling
you if it's bullish or bearish, okay?
Um,
it doesn't filter on volume. Don't think
of it filtering on volume. This average
range is is a is a
is the algo basically, okay? It's not
volume by itself because, you know,
every market trades different. Um, you
know, different volumes. Let's say you
were going to go look at um,
live cattle futures.
Okay?
Here, right?
The bearish signals, bearish signal,
bullish signal right here before it
jumps up, right? On this move up. On
this move down.
Um,
you know, every market trades different
volumes, all right? I mean,
you can see how the volumes are here,
right? In
in say this, you know, this is euro
currency, okay? But if again, you know,
if you change it to
cattle, LE, you're dealing with
you know, much different volumes in the
market, okay? Which much lighter.
But you're still getting, you know, the
buy and the and the sell signals.
Okay, so it's it's not
pure volume.
Um let's see if I asked it. How does it
work
on longer time frames? Okay, like bonds.
Okay, let's take a look here at bonds.
And
you know, 5 minutes, 10 minutes.
Let's see what settings I got here. So
150 and 6, you know, if I'm starting
going out and further in time,
anytime testing a new market, I would
drop the disparity range down to the
lowest. I'd turn off, you know, any of
the filters I've got on.
I would still keep trade entry signal,
but I'd probably make it 1 and 3.
And again, you know, starting at the
lowest range, you know, 50,
that's probably too
too low for me. Um
but you know, it's a starting point,
right? Then you'd go
you know,
back
to you know, you then you can either put
the momentum strength on. If it looks
like that's too messy, messy in the
sense of too many signals, then your
disparity range is set too low.
Um then you might want to add on the
momentum strength, clean it up a little
bit.
Okay?
And you know, maybe bump it up to, you
know, whatever, 100.
I might say 89.
89's a fib number. Um there's nothing
magical about it other than being a fib
number.
Um
you can start to see, you know, that's
not a nice signal there.
I don't really like that.
You know,
go a little bit lower, 75.
And
similar signals. This is on a
But again, you know, today is
kind of a quiet day.
Um, you know, go back to Friday.
The day before.
That's on a 5-minute chart.
On 10.
Sort of the same settings.
I don't know.
15 minutes.
Yeah, honestly, on days that it trends
well,
looks better than
choppy days, but
it's just one of those things. Um, you
know,
I I don't look at bonds more than 5
minutes.
I don't know. For me, if I'm looking at
a minute base chart
with bonds, I'll go about 5 minutes is
about as far out as I would go
personally. Um, and again, you could
even
Another thing to you could play around
with is turning off the trade entry
signal as well.
All right, but again, you don't I don't
want to take some of these trades like
this short here.
That's what the trade entry signal will
keep you out of a trade like this one
here or trade like this one here.
Uh-huh. Steven says, "Yeah, I got run
over by the Swiss National Bank once."
Yeah, I remember that. What year was
that? Uh
2016.
A lot of traders got run over that day.
So, it was a long time ago. Not a long
time ago. It was It was 8 years ago.
But, yeah, I'm little I always like to
look at Swiss franc just
because that was when I started on the
floor, that was one of the
Swiss franc and Deutschmark was
the markets that uh
I was focused on.
So, I always have that in the back of my
head.
Um
I mean, ES, MES, it's all the same.
You know, a lot of these markets there's
not much difference between
you know, how they trade. So, you could
I said the default of 150 and 6. It's a
good starting point for all markets.
And I'll even
um you know, then when you get into some
uh
you know, this is what trade This is
What do we got it set at here? 75, which
is kind of low.
Trade entry signal turned off. I I do
believe you know, on on an equity market
you
do need to have it on.
Um
Again, the default settings of 150
and 6, I think is
you know,
a good starting point for equities,
E-minis, Nasdaq.
And go from there.
Um
You know, Dow, we had that big run up
this morning.
Right off the cash open. Well, we didn't
see it rose
What did it go up like 2 or 300 points?
I don't think there was any buy signal
with that default setting.
I know some people say, "Well, I didn't
catch this run up here." Okay, well,
sometimes it it doesn't catch that run.
I mean, that was a a monster move from
Again, this is a 5-minute chart from,
you know, 300 all the way up to
600.
But, on the 1-minute chart, I'm pretty
sure it didn't catch that.
There's other things you could have
caught with the order flow, but you can
see this morning, just, you know,
overnight, since Europe,
it's just been all institutional buying.
This is the 5-minute chart.
Sorry.
But if you go down to
1 minute,
right, remember that that was that big
move up there?
This is That's the indicator setting.
75 and 6. But at 150 and 6, I don't
think it caught it.
So again, you know, you got
to remember, right, that the default
settings
are just that, they're just default.
It's a starting point for most markets,
but some markets,
depending on how they move, if they're
very fast-moving markets, you probably,
um, you know,
want to adjust it more for your market,
cuz you're on mini Dow. So what would it
look like every
This was failed, that failed, these
failed, these failed.
But since this morning, early, right, it
was catching the institutional buying
earlier.
But this is just a volatile market, and
volume is being distributed throughout
bars. I mean, you know, you got a bar
that jumps from 203 20 321 up to 4, or
to 381. So it's, uh, what is that,
60-point move, and then next bar another
60 points, next bar another 60 points.
Volume is being spread out, so it's
going to be
hard to really capture what's taking
place in there, just cuz the
volume is not, uh,
distributed normally.
Okay, and it's almost as if there's,
you know, when when you're trading,
you know, if you if you have ever traded
in the evening session,
evening means, you know, anytime from,
you know, the hours or European hours
versus the the day session.
You know, the volume is going to be
different, okay? So, for most normal
markets
like Dow during the evening session
the you could use the default settings,
but during the day you might need to
adjust it.
Um
Question here, will it work on Renko
charts?
Well
depending on the Renko charts that
you're using. If you're using the native
ones on
um
NinjaTrader
I forgot the name.
Um it won't because you need tick
replay, right? And it doesn't use tick
replay.
But you know
if you're on a chart like say
Heikin-Ashi that, you know
you're using tick replay
you can do it, right?
Now there Excuse me, there are some
Renko charts that do use tick replay.
Um
I think uh
I can't think of who
The Indicator Store Pablo's got a a tick
uh a Renko chart that uses
tick replay. Actually, I think it's for
free on his website, but um yeah, you
got to have
tick replay to use it, okay?
Um
I'm just curious. Yeah, I'm I'm kind of
curious here, so this is
the Renko chart.
Anyway, let's go back here to a simple
Can you show trading as example you show
for the E-mini 1-minute chart.
Uh, I got a problem with my e-mini data
today.
I'm just curious, is there anybody um
over the weekend
So, like this data comes from Kinetic.
Uh, not this data. This this one I have
on my other PC Kinetic data.
And over the weekend I got a huge bill
from them. Um
apparently they
screwed up their billing.
I was like thousands of dollars. But um
as opposed to this this data comes from
NinjaTrader Continuum.
But Dave, I'll get to your question um
privately there about that
e-minis.
Can you send me the online break charts?
I don't know. Um
line break charts.
Uh, the line break here.
I don't know because you need tick
replay, right? If you don't have tick
replay
it won't work.
Okay.
But you know, you could use it on
volume-based charts.
All right, you could use it on
tick. I don't know.
I don't know what it's I don't know I
don't know what is a good tick chart for
this market.
All right.
And again, you know,
depending on the different type of chart
you're using cuz again, not everybody
uses the same chart. So, you probably
need to adjust your disparity range,
your momentum strength, etc.
Um you know, if you're on a tick base
chart. So, for example, say
like
soybean meal
Okay.
You know, I wouldn't use a 250 tick
chart there. I'd probably use something
like a 50 tick chart.
All right.
Catch some nice moves down here.
You will say, "Wow, soy bean meal."
Well, this is from here to here is
200 bucks right there.
Right in this little move that you got
going on here.
It's already like 60 70 buck move. Um
again, yeah, you'd have to adjust it
based off of
your market. You got to do some testing.
I I can't give everybody
one set of settings because every market
is incredibly different in terms of
volume and and and how they trade. So,
you know, while
is pretty good in capturing, you know,
in in terms of the default setting for
most markets.
You can sort of I don't want to use the
term optimize,
but there's going to be times where you
could get
you know, by by lowering the disparity
range
um
making a little bit stronger or by using
a swing filter or by using the momentum,
um you know, that's going to help you
sort of zero in on what's a good
set of settings for your market.
Okay.
Um
let's see here.
I'm going to ask NQ. Oh, it's
NQ MNQ similar. So, I'll just throw up
MNQ.
Okay.
And I believe this is the default
settings here, 150 and 6.
Right? So, we're going back there kind
of a choppy.
Oh, that's 50 tick. That's why it looks
choppy. Um
Just going back to the uh 1-minute
chart. But again, you know, I even when
I look at MNQ, I don't look at a
1-minute chart. I prefer
30-second chart.
Okay.
And again, this is with the default
setting.
Um
which might Yeah.
Again, this market trade Yeah, it's got
a high
volatility relative to you know, other
markets. So,
you might want to lower the disparity
range from 150.
Again,
I've sort of fixated on 89 for some
reason, but uh you know, you could use
100 so you could see here. Again, it's
nice.
You know, you're fighting against the
current there, but then it gets you
right here. It gets you right here.
Little back and forth out of the cash
open. Once cash opens, um the big push
down.
Institutional buying coming in here.
Little back and forth. So, you know, 89
might be too much or sorry, too little.
So, again, you know, you could adjust it
to maybe 100 or 125.
You see how some of these come right
back to the price here, here, here.
But again, I don't use these as
potential targets like say I get a zone
drawn out here where I just drop an
offer looking for the market to come
right back to this level
and then sell off. But
you know, if the market is going up, it
could be an area to take profit. Cuz you
can see every time it came back up to
this level, it just sort of rotates
around, rotates around, rotates around.
Um
somebody asked about MBO data market uh
no.
We've got our own ways of doing it.
Um is the signal on the entry bar
Roger asked or the bar prior? Well, it
depends if you're using the the trade
entry signal. Trade entry signal is
going to shift it to the bar that's
moving.
But if you don't use the trade entry
signal, then it will appear
on the bar. So, just really quick here,
it's a little easier to show you this.
Um
Okay, so
you see right here.
Okay, this is your signal bar cuz it's
got the zone being drawn out.
But the trade
the actual signal here
it's not coming in on the next bar. It's
coming on this bar, the one that starts
the move.
Okay?
If
I disable this trade entry signal
All right, you can see the signal right
here is coming in
on this bar.
Okay? Still got signal coming in cuz
this bar has got one. This bar has got
one.
Okay? And you see there's a
sell signal up here.
But if I have trade entry signal on,
it's actually not a valid trade cuz it
didn't move one tick within the next
couple of bars.
All right.
See, so it's gone there.
Let's take a look at some more questions
here.
Yeah, Rune asked about the settings.
There there is in in the user guide
there's a little cheat sheet. There's I
go through some of the settings in
there.
Um
I'm going to also add on
this
this slide here.
Common settings. I'm going to add this
to the user guide later.
Anton says, "Can you use it with context
cuz otherwise it will destroy your
head?" Well, that's why I like to use
the um
either here
Okay, let's just go back to
let's go back to crude.
Um
So for example,
Okay, I'm going to turn on the swing
filter.
Turn off
the momentum strength, disparity range.
I'll just keep it at 89.
Okay.
So what it's doing is it's looking for
swing lows for bullish signals or swing
highs. Now again, I have it set at five,
which is kind of quick, but
you know, if if you want like
uh
longer swings,
um you know, set it at 50.
All right, so see right
bearish, bearish, bearish, some bullish,
bearish, bearish.
Okay,
and I'm going back here.
You know,
thing to keep in mind when you're using
the swing filter, if market is dropping
and you get some bullish signals and it
still drops
like here, here.
It you know, these two end up failing.
But again, you can catch some nice
moves. You know, this is a move from 70
down to 30.
And you can deal with the stop out here
and a stop out there.
But then you can do you know,
it depends on what kind of context you
want to use. There's different a lot of
different contexts in the market.
Swing highs and swing lows is a good
context.
Um
Okay, Mark, yeah.
Take care of that.
Um Eduardo asked, "What's the difference
between Delta Scalper and this product?"
Well, it's completely different order
flow analysis
um that's being read. So,
it's
this doesn't read the Delta.
Delta Scalper reads Delta.
This one reads uh volume and
compares it.
Um and let's take a look at DAX.
Okay, this is DAX with the uh
Well, again, this is a 30-second chart.
But again, this is with the
swing filter
ramped up to 50.
If you take that off, again, you know,
depending on how you want to trade,
you know,
you know, we'll start and with just the
default here, 150 and 6.
Okay.
Nah.
Too much.
Yeah, kind of curious.
I would look with 250.
Turn off this. Like I I didn't show you
anything with 250.
This is 250.
Set at the highest.
Again, that's a 30-second chart. Just
kind of fast
for a lot of markets.
Go back to 150.
So, 1-minute DAX chart
here, 150 and 6.
And
check this out. We'll add the prominent
point of control uh sorry, that's 150
and not 6, just 150.
150 and 6 looks like this.
Okay.
Add prominent point of control.
All right, you see how it removes a
bunch of these. And you can try the
prominent point of control without the
momentum filter.
And you're getting a couple sells in
here that aren't really working out, but
there's some nice ones in here.
Bunched up here.
And so, yeah.
But yeah, DAX is a nice market, also.
Got a big margin for traders, but um
a nice market.
Anthony asks, is this available on Gold
Charting? Not yet. Not yet. Um
What is the best for newbies?
If you're new to trading,
and I tell people this, if you're if
you're new to trading, choose an easy
market. You know, it always kills me. I
see traders coming into the market.
They're they're new to trading,
and they jump right into Nasdaq. You
know, there's so many other markets out
there.
Um you know,
currencies, you know, a market that I
think is for a good market for
people relatively new to trading is
5 years.
Cuz you got to think of, you know,
getting in and out of a position. You
know, does it provide liquidity? Um and
you know, not granted, you know, it is
an interest rate,
but it doesn't move um you know, the way
Nasdaq moves or anything, but you can
see, you know, 5 years here, right? You
can even turn off some.
It's it's a good contract
just in general that I think are new to
trading.
It does trade decent volume. You can
read the order flow.
Um
you know, but you can just see here,
these are the signals
in the 5 years.
All right.
So, last thing, you know, if you're new
to trading and you're trading with real
money, there's nothing wrong with that.
You know, I I don't like that nowadays
everyone says, "Oh, you have to if
you're new to trading, you have to
go through funding the account." Well,
you know, that's just a new thing in the
last 10 years. Um
nothing can replace trading with real
money.
Yeah, Craig.
It's funny cuz then I I cuz I got like
two bills from Kinetic. Yeah, one was
from
the one and the other one was like this.
And it's like
I wrote to Kinetic and like, "Dude,
what's going on?" And they're like uh
"So, do you want to cancel your Kinetic
your subscription?" Like
But uh I I think a lot of people are
getting uh
are getting uh same thing.
But anyway, guys, um
I'm going to end it there. You know, my
throat is killing me. I don't want to
keep you guys on all day. I'll take a
look at these questions and you know,
like I'm going to send out the replay
and you know, some of these questions
that I just didn't have a chance to get
to
um
uh I'll try and write them up in the in
the email. But again, I don't want to
keep everybody on too late. It's already
uh
12:10.
So,
thanks. And Paul, I'll take a look at
your email as well.
Um
just give me a second here. Let's write
this down.
So, anyway, guys, uh just you know,
check your email later this evening for
the the replay.
Um we've gone past the 1-hour mark and
GoToWebinar does Once you get past 1
hour, it takes longer to to render the
video. And again, you know, if I didn't
get to your question, I'll I'll going to
go through the questions again and I'll
take a look at them and uh I'll I'll try
and address them in the email that I
send out with the link to the replay.
So, thanks everyone for coming out and
uh again, just really quick um you know,
the link I'll just throw in the chat
here for you guys if you're interested
in getting it. I said, you know, it's
it's a great tool to have. Um I'm not
trying to like hard sell you guys,
really. I just want to talk about what
the indicator does
how to use it, show you different
markets today. Um just go to
orderflows.com/showhand.
Um simple.
Uh so, thanks everyone for coming out
and have a great uh rest of your Monday.
It's Veterans Day here in the US, so
it's uh kind of a public holiday. So,
take care everyone and I'll catch you
guys next time. Bye-bye.